[Music]
one of the perks of your job
obviously is that you you get to travel
you get to travel the world when you
make movies i know for
for the guard you shot in ireland in
kanama in galway yeah how was how did
you like being in ireland i loved it
yeah not a lot of black people there
your kid isn't the reason why i loved it
i mean really
that could have come out not as black as
i was told yeah exactly
no that was a surprise to you it was a
surprise i see a lot more
jackson's than what williams no um
it was it was but it was great i mean
that that that country
particular that part of the country is
like mars
you know it's another place it's vast
it's stark those
you know stone walls that people just
kind of said well this is my property
line why because i put a wall here and i
this is that's kind of the rule in
ireland is it if you just lay some
stones in a circle you get to have
whatever's inside that's right
that's yours if you're asleep at night
and someone's put stones around your
house
you gotta move yeah exactly that's their
house now their house now
now there's a rumor i have to ask you
about it was a story that i've seen
printed a bunch of places and it was
surprising to me and it said don
cheadle is going to play conrad murray
in the conrad murray story
uh you know michael jackson's position
and i was like what
really what's going on with that how did
this rumor get started first of all is
it true
no okay so how did this get started i
was do
it was one it was in a press junket and
it was one of like the 11
000th interview i had to do and i was
drunk by then let's face it
and uh i think you're drunk now i'm
pretty drunk now yeah
and it was getting it was sort of an
irreverent moment and they said so
what's the next project you want to work
on i said i want to do the conrad murray
story
and i want to do it in drag because
that's that way i'll ensure that i get
an oscar
and next thing i know it's uh don
cheadle doing the conrad murray story
they just went with that story they went
with it
yeah yeah what they did you know i'm
drunk
by the way that is not an excuse with
the press no hey wait a minute i was
drunk
cheadle drunk yeah cheatle drunk out of
his mind